welcome back to the Entertainment
Tonight comic-con sweet on Kelty night
and we're joined by the cast of
Stumptown a new P I sort of show that
his very sassy coming to ABC this fall
so we're very excited to welcome the
cast of the sweet hello everyone okay
first of all this is sassy for you and I
like it word it's like you saying it
right feel very confident I like her
already that she's sassy she's sassy but
she's also like she's a little bit of a
mess but sure you know her humor gets
her through a lot of that stuff so how's
the comic-con experience been so far you
guys were doing signings the fans are
everywhere it's pretty wild I mean today
seems like a lot crazier than yesterday
but we did some signings and it's always
nice to meet fans and there everyone's
been so wonderful and positive does
everyone feel the pressure of taking
care of America's best friend Colby
right yeah yeah we love her we care
about Colby a lot like even though she's
Canadian you know she is America's best
friend it's a lot of responsibility news
to me I might bury into this title right
it's not into it you know America's
Sweetheart Julia Roberts America's best
friend is you oh yes
so don't wreck her yes we as a cast when
she's not around talk about it a lot
yeah you know we need to protect her
yeah sure America's best friend is taken
care of
yeah it's a major priority you're
looming over it
because I saw in the trailer there looks
to be a lot of danger coming your way
yes are things blowing up yeah she's not
seeking that out danger oh he seems to
find her and there will be a lot of
action in the show there's a lot of a
lot of fights a lot of a lot of driving
a lot of yeah but it's gonna be pretty
pretty intense very cool so it's perfect
that we're here at comic-con talking
about this because the show is based on
this graphic novel so what does that
mean to be this is like the og place
where that type of genre is celebrated
so how cool is it to be here celebrating
oh it's for you
it's yeah it's it's a little bit
startling
and well it's a it's a big production
and so well coordinated the people that
we have taking us from place to place
scheduling it is a breeze I don't know
enough for them they're like it has been
my worst yeah um okay so your husband I
just saw your pictures from the up front
your husband is on the ABC show as well
yes and so now you guys like the
contract right won't do it unless my
husband I know it and vice versa yeah
and he's your lead-in right yes yes so
how's that at home
how's that pressure well I have it you
know it happened to see what our day at
the river yeah that's gonna be really
intense in that house it's it's I'm so
grateful it's so wild
it's a while to be like we're both
working and we're both working in the
same city yes Koby we need a leader
come on honey bring the laughs great
single parents is a wonderful show I
have no worries it's one of our
executive producer Aaron's favorite show
that's so hilarious and funny yeah so
you're fine but you know we know where
to go if things aren't going well you
know I feel like that's up to us and
we're gonna make an amazing show and
people are gonna tune in and love it
tells you go and love it I love it all
right so you're playing a private
investigator how good are you at picking
up the clues my god she's not great
she's not your national I'm not MJ he's
not she's not your traditional PI you
know and I think also the role of a PI
within society is a really intriguing
one it's sort of a job that that where
you have to sort of do the work that the
police department won't do yeah and and
jobs that are very personal and also
very emotional like finding out if
somebody's cheating you know a stalking
situation it's very weird and dark and
complicated so the cases that we're
gonna take on and the show aren't gonna
be you know black and white they're
going to be very
they're gonna be in the gray now have
any of you ever hired a private
investigator to investigate anything
before have you ever been I've always
thought about it yes yeah like I want
someone to find out why I love to eat so
much for that yes have you ever had a
pie you know I hired a pie when my
girlfriend was getting cheated on and
like I think it was savage and it was so
interesting I think did they find yes
Wow they were kissing on a picnic table
and there were photos Ireland and I do
watch the show cheaters a lot and I've
seen Greco catch them fools cold handed
for that surveillance you got them so um
but all jokes aside this is actually
you're bringing attention to a real
serious thing and bring you some light
to females in the military and when does
that responsibility mean to you well
first of all I respect anybody who
enlists in the military I mean it is
such a such a sacrifice and such a brave
noble thing to do so I'm always
intrigued and excited to bring these
characters onto screen so we can really
honor them but what you're talking about
specifically is that my character
suffers from PTSD which i think is a
pretty common theme within people who've
experienced trauma not only in their
lives but in service and my character
does not deal with it like doesn't even
acknowledge it and kind of berries yeah
so I think throughout the series we're
going to see how that how that creeps up
on her and and hopefully how she seeks
treatment for that I love that Michael
speaking of things creeping up on you I
saw your old age photo on your Instagram
you look good
god bless you yeah what was it like to
look back at it old Michael look back at
well first I didn't do it my Gary did it
and when I saw it it was it was kind of
creepy to be honest with you because he
didn't have my same arms and yet my face
was 30 years older so I guess it's good
lotion
you know sunblock on your mic is already
78 years old already looks good okay so
it is comic-con weekend and I just want
to know there's a big Marvel thing
happening tomorrow bo is just wondering
if you're going you know like a big
reveal and if you could like maybe just
tells me on vacation I mean are you
gonna buy you laughing Marvel related I
don't I did enough I do I know well
enough to keep my male because
apparently Chris Pratt is in town
Angelina Jolie is in town oh yeah I know
what it's about but I'm not so you do
not just see America's best friend right
now
if you want to keep your title of
America's best friend tell America all
of our easy tomorrow I love I love
spoilers people like I got a no it's
tomorrow it will be all over the news
tomorrow so you're gonna be working with
Angelina Jolie I know I have nothing to
it I just know what it's about
that is what you just said that is
breaking their way to America's boss Ron
will be working with Angelina Jolie
[Applause]
and Michael Ealy is 102 years
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]